so CNNMoney reporting this saw this a
couple days ago and dreams our producer
pulled it up this morning oh yeah we
talked about this Americans have racked
up billions billions with a be a billion
is a thousand million worth of overdraft
charges in 2016 US consumers paid a
total of fifteen billion dollars in fees
for bouncing checks which is when a
customer tries to make a purchase
without enough money in their account to
cover the transaction according to new
data released by the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau wonder who they're
really protecting all banks with assets
over 1 billion dollars must report how
much money it brought in via bounced
check and overdraft fees and this year
the industry rang up eleven point four 1
billion that's up two and a half percent
from 2015 adding in its best guess for
what smaller banks and credit unions
charge the CFPB stands for we don't do
much says fifteen billion dollars is
roughly the grand total these fees are
particularly troublesome for
cash-strapped Americans says the CFPB
director Richard Cordray in a press
release despite the recent regulatory
and industry changes consumers with low
account balances a little margin for
error continue to pay significant
overdraft fees he also pointed out the
average amount of money consumers
overdraft is about $24 the banks often
charge fees of around $34 for each
incident so you go to dinner and spend
$24 you bounce check it cost you double
more than that one now this is
particularly troubling if
a billion dollars a year because you
won't do sixth-grade math how stupid are
you
that's unbelievable
you're giving up 15 billion dollars of
your money because you write a check or
use your debit card and there's no money
in your account and you act like that's
going to be okay unbelievable now this
is not a lack of financial education at
all because any doofus knows that if you
write a check or use your debit card and
there's no money in your account it's
going to bounce any doofus knows you're
going to have overdraft fee's you don't
have to have a financial education you
don't have to go to a class you don't
have to read a book to figure that out
any doofus knows when you write a check
or use your debit card and there's no
money in there it's going to cost you
out your butt you know this it's
unbelievable I used to be one of those
doofuses I mean I have any money and I
live right on the edge and I would play
the game of beat the check you don't
beat the check is you write the check
and hope you get your check from work
into the bank before that check you
wrote gets to the bank and if you play
beat the check you're one of the
doofuses it creates 15 billion dollars
in revenue for the banking industry this
is not a lack of education I mean you
don't have to have a class on how to not
bounce check really I mean truthfully
there is not that much to this I am a
bounce to check in decades oh you got
plenty of money is why no I can actually
add and I know how
which is in my checkbook checking
account and I don't write checks for
money that is not in my checking account
oh why is it hard that's ridiculous
this is the dumbest thing on the planet
I mean there's a lot of stuff you can
argue about if you want to but simply
writing a cheque or using your debit
card when there's no money in your
account there's nothing you can call
that it's not like well we have a
different opinion on how to use for 9jo
instruments no you're just stupid I mean
this is just straight-up Dom it's a lack
of self-control and a lack of basic
organizational skills
you can't walk past some stupid butt
item without buying it even though you
don't have the money to buy it if you
don't have the money to buy it don't buy
it because you're going to get charged
freaking double that's the average here
a $25 check $24 check with a $34 set of
charges over double and then scratch
your head and wonder why you're broke
and you say stupid but stuff like little
man can't get ahead
well don't be stupid then it makes it
harder to get ahead if you're stupid
this is not rocket science you guys it's
really not all you have to do is
actually figure out what money you have
and don't spend more than that that's
all you have to do it's ridiculous
and it's really time you did this we hit
some basic stuff here I'm going to get
control of my life I'm going to ride
down get your every dollar budget going
go to every dollar calm and get your
budget it's free get your budget it's
free it's your budget it's free get your
budget it's free unbelievable and know
where your money is going and don't
spend money you don't have and so here's
the thing
if you don't have money in your checking
account
don't use your debit card oh it's deep
that's real difficult to grasp in it if
you don't have money in your checking
account don't write a check really I
mean you think payday lenders are a
ripoff payday lenders only charge eight
hundred percent they don't charge a
thousand percent you want to analyze the
interest rate on borrowing twenty four
dollars and paying thirty four dollars
to do that you want to know what I mean
a thousands of percent this is stupid on
steroids unbelievable you have to stop
this you have to get control of your
money when you stopped giving banks
overdraft fees that's when you know
that's going to be the start of you
turning your life around and listen I
don't care if you're 57 or you're 27 or
you're 16 or you're 15 or you're 13 you
can do this addition
I'm not good with numbers I'll believe
me you got out of a sixth-grade please
seriously it's addition and subtraction
there's no money in the account don't
write a check fifteen billion dollars
the bank's dirty little secret they make
more money on that and credit cards
going to do anything else and they're
going to be real quiet about it does
their milk and you people and you're
standing back and letting it happen
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]